yeah welcome to this video a new 15
minute game against Ozzy door off from
Russia not sure ever played this guy
from okay the scotch yeah hmm yeah come
on check my old favorite let's check on
before it I can't help it this is
probably one of the better lines forward
with taking a Bishop d3 I always like to
play Queen edge for here but then it's
probably not so great after Queenie to
hmm yeah the same choice is d 6 on 97
it's both possible
yeah essence
how crazy is it to try tweenage for now
intending Knight f6 and g4 playing like
playing in caveman style yeah all right
let's let's try that if he refutes that
you refuse it whatever it done and makes
for an interesting video at least so my
idea is to play really it has mentioned
caveman star Knight f6 energy for and
get something on f 2 and h 2 and if
white is really ignoring it it is and it
can it can get really tricky
yeah very good and problem probably a
move that he considers 9292 to f3
there's also always this before idea
before a form harassing the the bishop
on 95
yep this is always an option ok let's go
ahead but wait wait what we did f6
Knight f3 Queen h5 he can maybe go in
five
hmm I have no idea very interesting yeah
okay let's let's do this let's do this
Knight f3 tweenage 5v5 takes Knight e5
now can I can if everything else fails I
can exchange queens and play the same
game it's not the end of the world
I don't know I always had a soft spot
for this Queen edge phone booth Knight
f3 really looks like the Moose go to
blame but after Queen age five there are
certainly some some ideas for white
okay at least an poor Queen g4s probably
completely useless so let's go here and
yeah the question is is he playing ePHI
for now like directly trying to blow me
out of the water or some some other
moves against the slow move about
besides h3 that may be but a tree is so
strange anyway I have be should reform I
rookie one but I can help against rookie
one I have an ID for this is actually
quite good rookie one is a bad one ok
but if 5 is there after a five I can
consider naija form it's not it's not
entirely stupid but I can also take de
595 yeah Queenie five rookie one I don't
think I have any any decent trick yeah
h3 i really i really thought would be
out of the question but maybe it isn't
okay if I played yeah I know if I just
take it
hmm
well Bishop e3 is probably probably real
nonsense takes Queen takes and he's even
got night age too yeah that's nonsense
but I haven't even have an even luckier
idea but okay that's not working I was
even thinking about g5 but he can he can
just take take with the night
hmm
so what would be the the the same move
is that same move
yeah maybe something like 97 25 or
something
hmm but okay is she threatening
something substantial maybe I can just
castle why not
just intending new create playing normal
moves okay and the queen is actually is
obviously I'm making him a bit nervous I
had since understand all
so what about this let's go for that
keeping an eye at the e4 pawn and if it
takes on c6 I can at least take on age 3
I mean at least
the question is yeah maybe he can play
Bishop to e3 possible
okay but you create why not I like to
have the Queen around it it seems to
make him nervous okay rook e8 just
rookie eight or a steady 55 yeah maybe
maybe if I've coming
rookie 85
hmm de5 Queen takes eight
just move furniture
yeah this is a very weird position de5
Quincy 684 create
hmm all kinds of weird weird tactics
going on
okay let's gamble on that I didn't
really calculate it only some rough
lines the e5 I was De Quincey six young
then then c5 Hanks and a a tanks I
wanted to take on deform maybe have
something better even I was briefing
with e5 rookie five quince a Quincy 658
but this last look strange LC seven
adults a complete nonsense so if 5mm d5
Quincy six I take on d4 with the porn he
can also take c5 with the Queen this is
what I didn't see I didn't really
appreciate
okay yeah Bishop d3 I have Queen g5
doesn't isn't a big problem the question
is how to set up pieces now maybe Bishop
e7 is not bad actually I bet okay 95 195
this is a move that can easily hurt and
a lot night h5 this is completely
ridiculous night 85 now it's it's mostly
misplacing the night 9725 would be nice
but I also at some point I need to
protect c6
ok
you see threatening me five maybe
yeah if i vas bit bitter and annoyance
i'm thinking i know this is nonsense I
thought Queen h5 briefly
595 sir glisson IDM
try to activate look here
um
hmm
awesome
thinking I ok McQueen mr. doesn't have
many squares always need to be cautious
night be 3 i'm not sure but i had more i
know it look more threatening to me when
it was in the center but it's more based
on field and on any concrete calculation
you 595 I don't know you can just play
Queen Bishop g3 yeah why this is what's
better here yeah those greenish four
moves like they they are interesting but
if they're good that's another matter
can i play night to each five
and down maybe I can only five I mean
I would maybe I can we can all right I
can't just take it higher intakes Bishop
takes and then 95 or something or eat
six yeah don't know
it's very complicated
this is also ideas like a 4c for
addressing the bishop on a4ai pretty
much need to play a 5 wait and therefore
i can actually take it too and because
the night is hanging on v3 it's
important
mm hmm interesting
more like a defensive move but g3n maybe
he's threatening g3 here
should I play Queen to h5
hmm
yeah let's try that it also cameras the
fifth-ranked so if he moves the Queen
I'm controlling this a 5 square and if
he exchanges at least I get a tempo on
the bishop I didn't I didn't didn't see
that move at all oh this is not a good
sign
hmm 32 g 6 mmm Bishop d3m wait but this
isn't so clear Bishop d3 i have i have
rookie 5 rookie 5 as an interesting move
if it takes then his dark squares are
kept catastrophe and I've got h5 coming
this is actually interesting maybe this
is a way to play but this also what
about Bishop g4 Bishop g4 hg Knight
takes this threatens a night thus to the
threat ins on f2 and a night discovery
where does he go
now this is good this is good just good
this is just good for black I think
unless I'm overlooking a very simple
technical idea that's f2 with both
pieces actually Bishop f2i night f2 and
then also 95 check and detecting the
Queen and the bishop on d3 so there are
various moves now 95-93 and so on and I
don't really see how he prevents it King
everyone i can take f2 and with the with
the night and this um this should be ok
I mean three pawns and the pieces are
active yeah he needs to do that ok um
and now Bishop Bishop f2 is also
something to consider but ok come on
keep it simple this gets the third pawn
on e5 as e5 is not possible simply
because these three hangs and I have
ways to continue if everything else
fails I can just take the three and
rookie six rookie aid he's just got an
open King now
yeah I think you miss Jett dead this is
no one this is no good for black
wow this is impish asst very ambitious
five
550 okay but mr. we see five so so so
terrible
mmm okay where would I actually move
this
wow what were warmer 1e5
wait wait would we do f5 maybe I can
play five year f5 come on if it takes f5
I take e 1 and have Queen g1 this should
be should be something
and ii five i play night you for
attending quincy one also or if I've i
can again maybe i can take it all so now
i can probably also just take it tap ok
eat eggs at five is probably the the
critical move
rookie one King you one quick g1 check
king d to a snowman maybe rookie head
intending Queenie one and it is very
dangerous but probably he needs to take
it I don't I don't think now maybe if
I've hard to part to play this
you five hundie only real alternative
taking it taking only five or 90 form or
d5 even I could also play d5 right this
looks it doesn't look dynamic enough
let's not spend ages here let loose on
time at the end now okay with this kind
of safe try it for safe play moves but
Queen a five or queen to have seven and
this is better I need to I need to
threaten details e5 and if it takes on
on d6 IFIF ruka fade winning the bishop
this is the thread anyway yeah yeah this
is good for black
okay rook rook e6e 62 g 6 this is the
probably the way to go Queen 85 look
everyone Queen h5 i'm still threatening
group g 6 and I've got queenie to coming
now still rock g6 and Queenie to unlock
each one we need to
and now the night is offside and the
King position
yeah I think what's busted him
I don't see a difference yeah very hard
to tell maybe this g4 was really what's
really really bad I was probably in some
trouble before that as Queen age for its
really asking for it a bit higher know
now he doesn't find a move yeah I don't
see one either just you know keep it
simple and now just age six probably
check with the pawn so that I threaten
rook h6 mate basically isn't the submit
what if there should be a maid somewhere
probably I'm just I'm just blind here
and don't see the maid check
mmm why am I not seeing a meteor ok can
I can take the rock but so I I really
hoped that should be made checkmate yeah
complicated stuff no idea I don't know
if this was maybe this was too much yeah
Bishop g4 it's good for black but ok the
computers and unclear something minus
0.2 which basically means nothing but
yeah maybe it wasn't so terrible oh I I
overlooked Knight takes e4 here have
their tactics everywhere maytex reform
yeah it's not so much F to the problem
check very cute getting the piece back
yeah but we'd be both missed that and
then this one here actually okay Bishop
g4 at the right move my first idea was
this which is not so bad strategically
because this is a very strong piece this
is a very strong working out I oh this
is very strong he can play see father
and this sports the fun okay but rookie
5s now it's not necessary because simply
this was was working and probably all
right um yeah I thinking of one is they
must he must do that something like this
gets very ugly
he never took him yeah and now I've
Unleashed this f5 movie which is really
a throwing yeah more petrol to the file
it's not working Mitch the comp says
white can take I had the hunch that he
could take but that's how to calculate
of course played this but let's have a
look take my idea was to do that check
and then wookie ate about the computer
just gives why the winning edge here
winning edge winning winning game I
really have a didn't I told you never
check here and this is not working he
can mix the bishop which which is
actually what I missed I missed that the
night protects the rook yeah then it
takes a five would have one for white
ready had three minutes on the clock
this is probably now unclear or
something yeah I know this winning now
the compounds to take with the rookie
form actually with a big edge for right
in this way and why it is clearly better
now this is Sir quite nice this seems to
to win for black rook fass seem better
but this is also good and yeah this wind
snow yeah what to create a game but
certainly interesting to watch I hope
you liked it thanks for watching